it was built in the late 1970s to
commemorate indonesia's independence
more than two hundred thousand people
can fit inside the istiklal mosque one
of the capital's most iconic buildings
from the outside the mosque has looked
much the same for decades
but sustainability was one of the main
motivations during recent renovations
this mosque is 42 years old and the
equipment had not been replaced for a
long time
as part of the renovation solar panels
were added to the roof for now they only
support a small percentage of the
building's electricity consumption
and thanks to low flow taps and
treatment facilities
water usage has dropped by more than 30
percent
the istiklal mosque's green initiatives
aren't just good for the environment but
for its finances too since its
renovation and its switch to more energy
efficient lighting the mosque's
electricity bills have more than halved
in april the mosque became the first
place of worship in the world to receive
certification for sustainable design
from the international finance
corporation
the renovations cost more than 35
million dollars paid for by the
indonesian government
we worked with the ministry of public
works to realize our vision of an
environmentally friendly mosque
on the outskirts of the capital
worshipers at this mosque started their
own water saving initiatives
with a low-cost innovation which uses
the soles of old shoes to create a
stopper to reduce the flow of water
we have 650
children who who study here about
reading quran we educate also
environment from from the beginning
the mosques management also collects
rubbish from the community so it can be
recycled
people
come to the portsmouth it is easier for
us you know to to influence them and to
educate them instead of we are inviting
people
polluted and sinking fast the indonesian
capital faces many challenges
eco mosques are just part of the effort
to help ease the city's environmental
burden
jessica washington al jazeera jakarta